[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم
لكم
[موسيقى]
التفاوض في اوكرانيا
ردوا علي العالم كبيره
للتفاوض
سمعونا معنا الليله ايضا
لن يغيب عن سباق الرئاسه اما ان يحضر
بنفسه او يحضر مرشحون انقلب عليهم او
انقلبوا علي
[موسيقى]
في اوكرانيا
على خسران
مهم جدا لكن نتائج الحرب بعد
المقبله ستكون صعبه جدا على اوكرانيا
فاستعاده خرسون مهمه لكن لا يجب الاستهانه
بالقدره العسكريه الروسيه ومع كل هذه
العبارات التي تسمى الانتصار
اختتم بلا كنه
المخابرات الامريكيه للقاء نظيره في
المخابرات الروسيه سيرجينال سكين واكد
البيت الابيض النابلس نقل لنظيره الروسي
رساله بشان عواقب استخدام روسيا للاسلحه
النوويه واناقش معه قضايا الامريكيين
المحتجزين في روسيا لكن وهذه من عندنا
نحن منذ متى كانت اللقاءات بين الجانبين
على هذا المستوى واضحه وصريحه بهذا الشكل
هذا فضلا عن انها علنيه وليست اتصالات جي
سوليفان التي كشفتها الصحف الامريكيه
يتحرك
في كل الاحوال هزيمه خرسان اثارت الغضب في
روسيا انتقادات طالت الرئيس الذي قتل
وجنيرالات جيشه بطريقه نادره الغضب كبير
وعلى جانب الاوكراني سعاده غامره لكن
السؤال الاهم الان ماذا بعد خرسان فاموسكو
تشييد التحصينات شرق نهر
سيكون ضروريا والاهم سعاده محطات الطاقه
والمرافق الحيويه الاخرى لكن الامر لن
يكون سهلا بعدما مسافه القوه الروسيه
المنصحبه الكثيره من الطرق الرئيسه
والجسور والسكك الحديده
لنلقي نظره على تفاصيل وتعقيدات الجغرافيا
على الارض
نطلع على هذين المعبرين هذان مع عبارات
انتونيسكي والنوفا كخوفقا وهما المعبراني
الوحيدان لنهر النيترو جنوب مدينه التي
تسي
اقترحها عسكريون ومحللون التقدم في قطاع
زا بوريجيا نحو ميليتو بول
وبرديانسك وهي النقطه الثانيه الواضحه لشن
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد كان انتصار
خيرسون مبنيا بالاساس على تحطيم سلسله
التوريد الروسيه ثم على اداء مدفعيات هاي
مارسل امريكيه لكن الجغرافيا الحرجه كانت
ايضا مواتيه للجيش الاوكراني تحديدا موقع
خرسان المنعزل غرب نهر النيبرو بدات
المدفعيه الاوكرانيه بالفعل العمل على
الضفه اليسرى لنهر الدين برو كما يتضح من
سلسله الانفجارات العنيفه التي سمعت في
تشابلينكا على بعد 45 كيلومترا جنوب النهر
وعدم وجود منطقه عازله على الضفه اليمنى
لنهر نيبر يسمح للضربات الاوكرانيه
باستهداف السلسله من البنا التحتيه
الحيويه لشبه جزيره القرم التي ضمها بوتن
في عام 2014
السلاح الاهم بيد كياف القناه التي تزود
شبه جزيره القرم بالمياه العذبه والتي
تبدا من نوفاكوفكا اصبحت الان في نطاق
قذائف الهاون الاوكرانيه كما ان خط سكه
حديد دوناتسكا ميليتو بول جان بوي وهو خط
الامداد الرئيس لمجموعه جيش القرن يقع
الان في نطاق صواريخ هاي مارس والتي لديها
القدره مره اخرى على تعطيل الخدمات
اللوجستيه للقوات الروسيه يقول محللون
عسكريون لصحيفه جورنال الامريكيه ان شبه
جزيره القرم اصبحت الان تشبه قلعه محاصره
تحت انظار زنسكي
[موسيقى]
العسكريه الروسيه بان موقف موسكو بشان
خرسان كان ميؤوسا منه اصلا منذ الصيف وان
ثغرات عديده ظهرت من بينها الانظمه
اللوجستيه القديمه في روسيا وعدم كفايه
الاسلحه عاليه الدقه اما الاكثر اثاره
للاهتمام فكان المستودعات المركزيه والتي
تمثل اهداف جذابه للاوكرانيين لتدميرها في
ظل هذه الاوضاع الاوضاع الميدانيه التي
تصب بشكل عام في صالح اوكرانيا كان
مستغربا ما تحدث به رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه الامريكيه الجنرال ماركلي عن
حلول دبلوماسيه للحرب مضيفا ان الامور
وصلت الى حائط مسدود بعد سيطره
الاوكرانيين على خرسان وعدم قدرتهم على
التقدم اكثر من ذلك بسبب الدفاعات الروسيه
لذا حان وقت التفاوض بحسب على الامريكي
لكن يبدو ان موقف ميلي لا يتوافق مع اداره
بيضاء التي اعلنت عن اربع مئه مليون دولار
اخرى من امدادات الاسلحه الاسبوع الماضي
اضافه الى حديث مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيكسوليفان عن انتصار خرسون
الجمعه بالقول انه اذا اختارت كيف وقف
القتال والاستسلام فستكون نهايه اوكرانيا
لذا بدا وكان نظريه التفاوض لا يؤمن بها
سوى مارك مالي وحدهم
اذا هي مواقف مختلطه في واشنطن حيث لاتفاق
بين العسكر والساسه على الوضع لكن حقيقه
الميدان راويه ان انتصار خرسون اعطى دفعه
معنويه كبيره للاوكرانيين وزياره رئيسها
اليوم اليها زادت الامل في تحرير محتلته
روسيا ربما منذ 2014 حتى وليس في الحرب
الاخيره فقط وما لا يقبل التشكيك يا طاهر
انا الانتصار الاوكراني الكبير كان بمثابه
روسيه كبيره جعلت صقور الحرب الروس يصعدون
انتقاداتهم نحو الجيش
للمره الاولى وجه ان شطاء المؤيدون للحرب
في روسيا اكثر انتقاداتهم لاداء الجيش في
اوكرانيا بعد الانسحاب المهين من غير سوان
كتب الكسندر دورين المنظر اليمني للهويه
القويه الروسيه ان المهمه الرئيسيه للزعيم
هي حمايه الناس والاراضي الواقعه تحت
السيطره
فتغير محذرا لا يمكن للسلطات في روسيا
تسليم اي شيء اخر وصلنا الى الحد الاقصى
طلب الحزب الشيوعي في البرلمان الروسي
والذي النادرا ما يتحدى الكراملين بتفسير
من وزاره الدفاع لاصدار الامريكي
بالانسحاب من خرسون لكن الاقتراح نسفه حزب
بوتن روسيا الموحده تكشف صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز ان بعض المحللين اشاروا الى ان
التصاعد الانتقادات يشير الى ان بوتن فشله
في ابعاد نفسه عن الانتكاسات المتكرره في
الحرب كالسابه لكن حجم الانتقادات لم يصل
بعد لتحميله المسؤوليه بالكامل بعض اكثر
الانتقادات المواجهه للجيش اتت من حسابات
مرتبطه بمرتزقه فاجنر التي انتقد مؤسسها
يبغيني بريجوزين جينيرالات الجيش الروسي
استدعى المتشككون في ما اطلق عليه
الكريملين مناوره خرسون التاريخيه في
انتقادهم يقولون ان المدافعين في
ستالينغراد ابان الحرب العالميه الثانيه
كان لديهم خيار التراجع عبر نهر فولكا
لكنهم لم يفعلوا ذلك بينما ما حدث في
خرسون هو العكس تماما جاء في افتتاحيه
صحيفه ميزه
فيزيمايا غازيتا ان قرارات بوتا ليست
للمناقشه وانه لا يستطيع ان يخطئ لانه لا
توجد اليه لتصحيح لكن المشكله لدى بوتن
اعقد مما ذكرته الصحيفه فمعروف عن رجل
الكرملين القوي انه يرى ان القائد الذي
يعترف بالخطا يقلل من مكانته ما يجعل
صفاته موضع شئ في القانون الروسي انتقاد
الجيش بشكل مباشر يعتبر جريمه الا ان بوتن
كان حتى الان متسامحا مع المتعصبين من
اليمين الذين انتقدوا روسيا باعتبارها لا
تقاتل بقوا كافيه هنا تسال عدد من
المعلقين كانوا قله لماذا لم تستخدم روسيا
ترى سانتها النوويه ولماذا لم يكن الجيش
الروسي يقصف الطرق في غرب اوكرانيا
المستخدمه لاستيراد الامدادات العسكريه من
الولايات المتحده واوروبا اسئله اذا معلقه
بانتظار اجوبه بذلك
معنى من ابو ظبي متحدث باسم السفاره
الاوكرانيه في دوله الامارات اهلا بك معنا
هناك من بدا يتحدث الصراحه عن التفاوض
وهناك من يرى انه هذا سيكون مقتلى
لاوكرانيا وليس في صالحها هل حان وقت
التفاوض كما قال ماكلي
مساء الخير يا مرشدنا الكرام مساء الخير
يا ستوديو ااا في البدايه اريد ان اقول ان
ان تحرير خيرسون وهو فقط احدى مراحل طرد
المختلين من ارضنا والتقدم نحو انتصار
اوكرانيا سنواصل تحرير ارضنا وشعبنا وعلى
روسيا انسحاب قواتها من الاعراب
الاوكرانيه داخل الحدود معترف بها الدوليه
وحتى من ناحيه النظريه لا ننظر في امكانيه
اي تنازلات بما يخص ارضنا لا يوجد فرق همم
بين خيرتهم
همم
بالنسبه
اصبحت بايادي الجيش الاوكراني ما هي
النقطه الجغرافيه التي يعني يمكن ان ترضي
اوكرانيا للتفاوض يعني هنا تتوقف هنا
تفاوض اصبح مسموحا ومقبولا ما هي حدودكم
والعسكري
مع معترف بها الدوليه يعني
1991 ونحن سنحرر ارضنا يعني حتى هذه
الحدود ولما نتعلم عن امكانيه المفاوضات
ويجب ان ناخذ النقطه المهمه في عين
الاعتبار ان بعض الكلمات عن ان يتسامح في
الضغط عليها او ستصبح عليها الى الحلول لا
تصب في مصلحهتها هي كلمات ومحدثات سخيفه
وزير خارجيه اوكرانيا
بالترك همم هذه التصور القديم عن اوكرانيا
الدوله
لا اليوم اوكرانيا
الشروق وستهدد اوكرانيا كيف وباي شروط
ستنتهي هذه الحركه ولكن البعض قل ان هذا
قد لا يكون في صالح اوكرانيا من باب
النخرسون كان بها مشكله تكتيكيه حقيقيه
لدى الروس فضلوا الانسحاب منها ولكن هذا
لا يعني انهم سيفعلون ذلك في المناطق
الاخرى التي ضموها اصلا وهذا تحصيل حاصل
بالنسبه اليهم لا يبدو انه خاضع للنقاش
همم بكل تاكيد يعني بالنسبه
لكنه هروب يعني من همم لان الجيش الروسي
كان مقر الهروب يعني في عدم همم
دبلوماسي انا ممكن اقول لكم همم بكل مسؤول
همم اوكرانيا لا تتخلى عن الدبلوماسيه لكن
تصريحات الكريم من الحاليه حول همم
استعداده للمفاوضات هي مجرد عمليه
استثمار من الدخان تحول روسيا اقناع
العالم بانها جاهز لاتفاق وجبنا لكنها
حقيقه تريد
قواتها ومواصله الحرب ولكن قد يهتز الى
يعني قد عامل الوقت قد يؤثر فيها ايضا
واربما وانتم تصاعدون كل هذا التصعيد تقرر
الولايات المتح في لحظه اتفاق ما مع روسيا
قطع الاسلحه عنكم والامدادات والتمويل
والمخابرات ماذا ستفعلون حينها هل
ستستطيعون القيام بكل هذه الانجازات
نحن لن نثق
بكلمات الموصوف الخادعه ونحوث الشركائنا
على عدم الثقه بروسيا كمان نعم نحن ندري
ان هناك همم
ويشوك في انتصار اوكرانيا ومع ذلك من
المستحيل انتصار في الحرب اذا اذا كنت لا
تثق يعني بالاتصال كان هناك من قال ان
اوكرانيا غير قادر على مقاومه لاكثر من
ثلاثه ايام لكن همم يعني مره تقريبا ليست
اشهر واقرانيه
خارجي
الامر الذي لم يصدقه والبعض ايضا لكننا
نشكر الذين يؤمنون بانتصار اوكرانيا
ويدعمونها ومعها الحقيقي
باسم السفاره الاوكرانيه في دوله الامارات
[موسيقى]
لا قمع للامن لا قمع الامن ولا عقوبات
الغرب الشارع الايراني
[موسيقى]
يد الام ياما شاف الطول هالمشوار
ومع هذا لسه بتعرف كيف تختار حليب المراعي
الطازج الفرق بين الامهات
ه عليها
كان متاكدا بانه خطير ليقود المانيا
للسيطره على العالم
في التاريخ
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على شاشه العربيه
العالم
بين ايديك
العالم في
[موسيقى]
الرياض
اهلا بكم من جديد بناءا على توجيه العاهل
السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز غادر
ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان الى
اندونيسيا
المملكه المشاركه في قمه قاده دول مجموعه
العشرين التي ستعقد في مدينه باريس
السعوديه ان الامير محمد بن سلمان سيزور
عددا من الدول الاسيويه لبحث العلاقات
الثنائيه ومناقشه القضايا ذات الاهتمام
المشترك
طوال نحو 70 عاما ارتبطت السعوديه
واندونيسيا بعلاقات قويه ان من خلالها
اوجه التعاون في كافه الصيده منذ نشات
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بينهما في العام
1948 ربط البلدين تاريخ طويل من العلاقات
حيث جمعتهما روابط دينيه واجتماعيه في
اندونيسيا تعد موطن اكبر عدد من السكان
المسلمين في العالم اما اقتصاديا فتجمعهما
عضويه مجموعه ال 20 فلكل البلدين اقتصاد
المتين يعد من بين الاقوى عالميا حيث ان
اقتصاد السعوديه هو الاعلى نمو في مجموعه
العشرين واندونيسيا واحده من افضل الاسواق
الناشئه اداء في العالم وفي مجال التعاون
التجاري تعد السعوديه الشركه التجاريه
الاول لاندونيسيا في الشرق الاوسط حيث
تجاوز حجم التبادل التجاري بين البلدين
خلال العام 2021 حاجزا 18 مليار ريال كما
تقدر نسبه الن مقارنه بالعام 2020 ب 37%
فيما بلغ التبادل التجاري خلال الخمس
سنوات الماضيه اكثر من 92 مليارات وعلى
الصعيد الانساني والاغاثي دعمت السعوديه
عبر مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه اندونيسيا خلال الفتره بين عامي
2005 و22 بمشاريع باكثر من 72 مليون دولار
في قطاعات منها الصحه والتعليم والامن
الغذائي
[موسيقى]
التقيال اول مره وجها لوجه كريم
لقاء ظاهره ودن وترحاب وباطنه خلاف وتوتر
جزيره بالي الاندونيسيه جمعت الرئيسيين
الامريكي جوبايدن والصيني
العلاقات بين البلدين الى ادنى مستوى لها
منذ عقود مع خلافات بشان مجموعه من
القضايا تشمل تايوان والتجاره ركزت
المباحثات بطبيعه الحال على ملفات تايوان
واوكرانيا والطموحات النوويه لكريا
الشماليه وهي ايضا من القضايا البارزه
خلال قمه مجموعه ال20
للاجتماع بتاكيد سعيه الدائم لابقاء قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه مع الصين على المستويين
الشخصي والحكومي مشيرا الى ان العالم
ينتظر من البلدين تدلينا الازمات وعدم
تطورها الى نزاع بينهما
[موسيقى]
ني جورج
اكس بوكس
همم
الصين والولايات المتحده مره عبر 50 سنه
حفله بالاحداث التاريخ هو افضل كتاب لذلك
علينا ان نستفيد منه العلاقات بين الصين
والولايات المتحده حاليا تمر بحاله تدفعنا
للاهتمام بها ولا تصب في مصلحه بلدين
وشعبين وليست ما يتوقعه من المجتمع الدولي
لاننا قائدين لاكبر دولتين في العالم
علينا ان الصيغه الطريقه المناسبه
للعلاقات لايجاد الاتجاه الصحيح للعلاقه
الثنائيه مستقبلا وتطوير هذه العلاقات
ومثل ما عبر الرئيس الامريكي عن رغبته
بتحسين العلاقات ابدا الرئيس الصيني
استعداده لتبادل الاراء مع الرئيس
الامريكي حول العلاقات المشتركه والمسائل
الاقليميه والدوليه واضاف ان العالم يتوقع
من الصين والولايات المتحده اداره
العلاقات الثنائيه بشكل مناسب
تحديات غير مسبوقه والعالم وصل الى مفترق
الطرق الى اين نمضي هذا سؤال يدور في ذهن
الجميع ويتوقع من الصين والولايات المتحده
ان تدير هذه العلاقات بالشكل المناسب
علينا ان نعمل مع كل الدول لبث المزيد من
الامل في السلم العالم والاستقرار
والتركيز على التطوير المشترك انا مستعد
لخوض نقاش صريح لتبادل الاراء معكم حول
مسائل ذات اهميه استراتيجيه في العلاقات
بين الصين والولايات المتحده والمسائل
الاقليميه والدوليه اتطلعوا للعمل معكم
سيد الرئيس لاعاده علاقتنا الى الطريق من
اجل مصلحتنا ومصلحه العالم
لكن حتى قبل ان يبدا الاجتماع بين
الزعيمين توقع مسؤول في البيت الابيض الا
يحقق الاجتماع وانفراجه دبلوماسيه وانما
قد يكون بدايه لاعاده ضبط العلاقه
الثنائيه اضاف المسؤول ان زياده التعاون
لن يؤدي بالضروره الى تقدم الجوهريا في
القضايا الشائكه مثل تايوان لكنه قد يفتح
قنوات الحوار في ظروف الصعبه وهو امر يحظى
بدعم من الحلفاء في المنطقه وتحديدا
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه واشنطن بوست نقلت
عن المسؤول الامريكي قوله ان بايضا يريد
التاكد من ان المنافسه بين البلدين محدوده
مع ايجاد قواعد واضحه للعلاقه تضمن عدم
انحراف
المنافسه بين واشنطن الى نزاعا او الصراع
رغم الاشارات الايجابيه بين بايضا وت شير
يرى محللون ان الامور قد تسوق طاهر بسبب
ملف تايوان بالتحديد نتعرف على التفاصيل
معك
بين الولايات وحيد والصين حزمه مساعدات
جديده لتايوان فالكونجرس يسعى لتسليح
تايوان بسرعه مع تمام التهديد الصيني عبر
مساعدات عسكريه غير مسبوقه لتاي باير قال
مسؤولون ان المساعدات ستسمح للجيش
الامريكي بتوفير الاسلحه لاول مره لتايوان
من خلال برنامج التمويل العسكري الاجنبي
هذا البرنامج يمكن تايوان من تلقي اسلحه
ومعدات مثل صواريخ كروز وانظمه الدفاع
الجوي والطائرات المسيره وانظمه القياده
يرى مشرعون امريكيون ان الدروس المستفاده
من حرب اوكرانيا تدفع لتسليح تايوان
وتدريبها مسبقا قبل اي هجوم محتمل من
الصين قال النائب مايكل ان الولايات
المتحده بحاجه لتسليح شركائها قبل بدء
اطلاق النار وهو ما يمنح لاي دوله الفرصه
لتجنب الحرب لكن العقبه في الوقت الحالي
هي عدم وجود اموال لهذه حزمه في مقترحي
ميزانيه العام المقبل والذي يعمل الكونجرس
على تمريرها واذا لم توجد مخصصات ماليه
لتغطيه تكاليف الاسلحه سيتعين على الرئيس
جو بيدن تقديم طلب طارق لتمويل الانفاق
لتايوان وتوضيح السبب وراء ذلك اعضاء
بالكونجرس قالوا ان الحزمه التي يتم
الانتهاء من تفاصيلها في قانون تفويض
الدفاع الوطني ستسمح بتزويد تايوان سنويا
بما قيمته مليار دولار من الذخائر
الامريكيه المخزنه وما يصل الى مليار
دولار من الاسلحه السنويه لمده خمس سنوات
مدفوعه باموال الضرائب الامريكيه يقول
مسرعون في الكونجرس ان المساعده ستكون
متسقه مع التزامات الولايات المتحده بموجب
قانون العلاقات مع تايوان الذي ينص على ان
سياسه الامريكيه تجاهها تايوان تقضي
بتزويدها بالاسلحه لتمكينها من الدفاع عن
النفس
على الطرف الاخر يتساءل مشكتون عما اذا
كانت المساعده ستعزز القدرات الدفاعيه
لتايوان على المدى القريب مع الفريق
الكبير في القوه العسكريه بين تايوان
والصين لا ننسى تحذيرات القاده العسكريين
الامريكيين السابقه من مطامع الصين احدها
هؤلاء الادمن الذي كان قائدا للقياده
الامريكيه في المحيطين الهندي
حذر قبل نحو عامين من ان الصين تريد
تحقيقه مكانه القوه العظمى بحلول الذكر
المئويه لتاسيسها عام 2049 وهو ما سيعني
ان تايوان هي احدى طموحات الصين قبل ذلك
الحين وفي ذلك الوقت فسر مراقبون هذه
الملاحظات بانها تعني احتمال حدوث غزونيه
لتايوان بحلول عام 2017
معنى الان من بالي راويه مفردات العربيه
ناديه البلبيسي لتغطيه هذه القمه اهلا بك
معنا ناديه ااا يعني صحيح انه لاول مره
يلتقيان كرئيسين ولكن بايدين التقى ااا
لمده 67 ساعه على الاقل مع تشيجن بيج
ايامها كان بيضا نائبا للرئيس في عديد من
القمم واللقاءات هل اطفا ذلك روحا من
الايجابيه همم انعكست على المحادثات بين
الرجلين وهل قرا الوفد الامريكي كل ما حصل
على انه ايجابي همم 100% لجهه تجميد
الخلافات
اولا طاهر بالنسبه لهذا اللقاء كما ذكرت
البيت الابيض يقول بالفعل لان الرئيس بعد
يعرف جيشيبينج منذ ان كان نائب الرئيس
والتقى معه مرت عده هذه المره الاولى وجها
لوجهك رئيس للولايات المتحده سئل اذا كانت
شخصيه شيشي بنجاميه او انه كان مستعد
للتنازل قال احده كما هو مباشر يتحدث ما
يدور في باله وبالتالي يمكن ان نقول باننا
نبقي على هذه خطوط الاتصال مفتوحه وبعد
ذلك ايضا طلب الرئيس همم من وزير الخارجيه
ان يذهب الى بكين اذا هي بدايه جيده دون
ان شكك هناك الكثير من القضايا ليست كل ما
ذكرته همم ايضا لكن هناك ايضا همم موضوع
اخر وهو انا الرئيس بايرن يريد ان يحيد
الصين في موضوع اوكرانيا طب طبعا غابه
الرئيس بوتن عن هذه القمه وبالتالي الولا
والتحدى تعمل مع باقي الحلفاء بالفعل
لتقويه موقفها بالنسبه لدعم اوكرانيا لكن
مره اخرى يقول الرئيس بيدن بالنسبه للصين
بان سياسه الاداره هي الابقاء على الصين
واحده بمعنى بانها لا تريد ان يكون هناك
تغيير همم سياسي بالنسبه لتايوان بمعنى
انها تريد اعلان الاستقلال وتدعمها
الولايات المتحده هذا لن يحدث وايضا لا
تريد للصين بالتحديد طاهر وراويه ان يكون
هناك ضم هذا الخوف ربما يريد الرئيس ان ان
يتبدد الا يكون هناك ربما قضيه اخرى على
يعني اذا حد ما مشابهه الى موضوع اوكرانيا
بالنسبه للغزوه بالتالي ايضا يريد ان يقول
للرئيس شيبينج بشكل واضح بان الولايات
المتحده تعارض ايضا ل- اا تايوان وهذه
رساله كانت واضحه من بعيد اليوم ناديه في
ما يخص جدول القمه ما اهم
اللقاءات التي حصلت وستحصل بالايام
القادمه لو سمحت
كنت بدي اقول انه تبدا غدا رسميا بس انا
نسيت الساعه 3:00 الصبح بتوقيت بالي
اندونيسيا يعني ستبدا خلال خمس ساعات
تقريبا انا بالنسبه عندي لسه بعده يوم
الاثنين على كل الاحوال هذه القمه ستمتد
على مدى يومين في الخامس عشر والسادس عشر
طبعا تحضرها همم مجموعه السبعه الصناعيه
الكبرى وهي كل اوروبا الغربيه الى جانب
اليابان وكان الى جانب الدول ذات الاقتصاد
المتين الذي له دور جيو سياسي في العالم
منها المملكه العربيه السعوديه والارجنتين
جنوب افريقيا المكسيك البرازيل وغيرها
وبالتالي ستركز على كل تحديات العالم من
موضوع الصحه الامن الغذائي التغيير
المناخي مواجهه ايوب ممكن شبيه بجائزه
كورونا استثمار بالبنيه التحتيه شراكه بين
الولايات المتحده ورئيس الاتحاد الاوروبي
ومجموعه الدول العشرين ب 600 مليار دولار
الكثير من قضايا التي سيتم بحثها وربما
يكون هناك ايضا حلول ليس فقط البحث في
قضايا العالم وتحديات العالم لكن هذه فرصه
لكل دول قاده مجموعه ال 20 لان يكون هناك
لقاء وجها لوجه وهناك طبعا هذا عن ذلك
هناك لقاءات ثنائيه على هامشاد القمه
ستجمع الرئيس بعيد طبعا نتحدث عن الوفد
الامريكي على الاقل مع رئيس وزراء
بريطانيا همم الجديد ومع رئيسه ايضا
ايطاليا الجديده للتركيز على الحرف
اوكرانيا
الى بالي شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه المعلومات
ان شاء الله المره الجايه تكون قدرت
تقنعهم يحطوا شاشه العربيه خلفك
والبركه فيك بالترجمه يعني ههه ههه شكرا
جزيلا البيبسي دائما
[موسيقى]
قال مستشاره لان القومي الامريكي جاكسون
ان انتهاكات ايران لحقوق الانسان يجب ان
لا تمضيه دون عواقب واعرب السوليفان في
بيان عن قلق الولايات المتحده البالغ ازاء
الاعتقالات الجماعيه والمحاكمات
للمتظاهرين في ايران
السياسيين في ايران واكد البيت الابيض بان
واشنطن تواصل مع الحلفاء محاسبه المسؤولين
عن قمع الاحتجاجات في ايران
واخبار جديده عاجله الان عن اداره
السعوديه للهجامات الايرانيه التي استهدفت
شرق اربيل كردستان العراق
ايران اذا تصاعد قمع هذا ضد المتظاهرين
الذين يبدو انهم مصرون على المضيق قدما في
هذه الثوره وفقا وصف الرئيس الفرنسي الذي
اغضب ولا يزال نظاما طهران عقب لقائه
باربعه ناشطات يناضلنا من اجل حقوق المراه
الايرانيه من المنفى اثنتان منهن تقيمان
في امريكا الرئيس الفرنسي قال ان النساء
في ايران ياخذنا هذه المعركه بشجاعه
استثنائيه في ظل تهديد حياتهن وحياتي
احبائين واضاف انها احتجاجهن على حكم
النظام قد فجر الفقاعه الايدولوجيه التي
كانت طهران ترسلها الى العالم بان
الايرانيين لا يريدون القيم الغربيه لكن
اللافت كان اللهجه مكروه الحاده وصف
الاحتجاجات الايرانيه بالثوره ليست المره
الاولى بالمناسبه اضافه الى اصراره على
ضروره تجديد العقوبات الاوروبيه التي
تستهدف الحرس الثوري معبرا عن تايذه لوجود
رد فعل ديبلوماسيا قويا وفرض عقوبات على
شخصيات النظام المسؤوله عن قمع هذه الثوره
اضف الى ذلك حزمه العقوبات الاوروبيه
الجديده التي قالت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه انا لينا بيربك ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي يهدف من وراءها لارسال اشاره
واضحه الى المسؤولين الذين يعتقدون انهم
يستطيعون قمعه وترويع وقتل شعبهم دون عوض
مشيره الى ان العقوبات الجديده ستهدف
الدائره الداخليه للسلطه في الحرس الثوري
الايراني وهياكل تمويلهم على وجه الخصوص
نموذج
نحن والكثيرون نضغط من اجل فرد عقوبه
تستهدف خاصه الحرس الثوريه وافراد النظام
في كل مره حول هذا الموضوع نحاول ان ننظر
الى الحقائق المفيده واعتقد انه ما دامت
الامور تمضي قدما فسيتم طرح هذا السؤال
اكثر فاكثر نعم انا اؤيد ذلك لان لدينا رد
فعل دبلوماسي قوي وعقوبات على اشخاص في
النظام مسؤولين عما يحدث في قمع هذه
الثوره
وكانت الجوله الاولى من العقوبات التي
اقرت في اكتوبر الماضي شملت حضر سفر
وتجميد اصول لخمسه عشر شخصا ومؤسسه لهم
صله بوفاه الشابه امين وحمله القمع على
الاحتجاجات بينما شملت الحزم الجديده 31
اسما بينهم وزير الداخليه الايراني بسبب
انتهاكاته حقوق الانسان مشكلات او ازمات
ايران لا تاتي فورادا او ربما اراد
الطهران ذلك ازمه برنامجها النوويه عالقه
ولا اتفاق نووي حتى يلوح في الافق حتى
ايضا الرئيس الفرنسي كان له راي في قصه
نووي الايراني الطويله فمكروه لا يرى
مجالا لاحراز تقدم في اتفاق ايران النووي
في الوقت الراهن وفي وقت توجه فيه طهران
غضبا داخليا همم تواجه غضبا شعبيه وخارجيا
دوليا تستدعي حلولا من خزائنها تضرب مقارا
لاحزاب كرديه في كردستان العراق قصف ادى
الى شخصين واصابه ثمانيه على الاقل بجروح
في سلسله ضربات بالطائرات المسيره
والصواريخ وهو الخبر الذي ورد منذ قليل
باذنه المملكه العربيه السعوديه لهذه
الطلبات
[موسيقى]
هذا الهروب الى الخارج لم يدخل على
احتجاجات الشارع التي تستمر بالاتساع رغم
القمعي والعنف المتوسط وكاله انباء نشطاء
حقوق الانسان الايرانيه هرانه افادت بان
336 متظاهرا لقوا حتفهم حتى الان في
الاحتجاجات كما تم اعتقال ما يقرب من
15,000 شخص في عمومي البلاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الينا من واشنطن حول موضوع اللقاء الذي
جمع الرئيس الامريكي ورئيس الصيني الدكتور
عقيل عباس الخبير في الشؤون السياسيه اهلا
بك دكتور
واحده تحدث عن سلام تحدث عن علاقات جيده
يريد ان يقيمها مع
الصين ولكن بنفس الوقت
يحضر او يدرس حزمه دعم عسكري للجزيره كيف
يمكن فهم هذا التناقض به المواقف
الامريكيه هل نحن امام سيناري جديد
لاوكرانيا
شكرا على هذه الاستضافه
لقائهم مع الرئيس الصيني اكد مواقف
امريكيه تقليديه
ربما وضحاها للجانب الصيني بخصوص ما يفعله
الكونغرس اعتقد الامر لا ينطوي على تناقض
تاريخيا معروف ان الكونجرس لانه لا يوجد
السياسه الخارجي ولا يتحمل عواقب السياسات
بخصوصها يذهب ابعد هو اكثر تشدد من
الاداره
تقليديا بخصوص هذه مثل هذه القضايا هو
اكثر تشددا بخصوص ايران بخصوص كوريا بخصوص
الصين فهذا يعني هذا جزء من اللعبه
السياسيه التقليديه في الولايات المتحده
الصين الامريكيه
وبالذات في اوساط لا تتمتع بسمعه جيده
خصوصا في اطار التهديدات التي اطلقت عنوان
وعلاقتها التي دافئه مع روسيا همم بذلك
انا اعتقد المواقف في الكونجرس طبيعه
للكونغرس
الى الرئيس هل استطاع باعتقادك ان يجمد
الخلاف مع الصين حول تايوان لصالح او
لحساب كسب موقف بكين فيما يتعلق باوكرانيا
الصين بخصوص تايوان
بمعنى اننا لا ندعم استقلال تايوان لكننا
في ذات الوقت لا ندعم ان تظن الى الصين من
دون رغبه علوان بهذا بمعنى
القاء على الاشياء كما هي منذ عام 1979
يعني القانون الذي مرره القندس ويعبر عن
السياسه الامريكيه سياسه الصين الواحده
همم ندعم صينا واحدا لكن من دون واحده
اثريه تفرضها الصين على تايوان على تايوان
على تايوان ان توافق على هذه الوحده اعتقد
في هذه اللحظه مثل هذا الموقف
نسبيا للصين لان هناك حسابات صينيه قد
تكون مبالغ بها بخصوص رغبه الولايات
المتحده في الدخول في صراع عل وربما عسكري
مع الصيني
راغب مثل هذه الصوره مثل هذا الصراع او
حتى مستعد له
هل تعتقد بانه بموضوع ان العالم يسعنا
حاول ان يروج له التشي في لقائه هل تعتقد
انه يعني منطقي صينيا بالفهم او بعقليه
النظام الصيني وهل تعتقد انه الولايات
المتحده يمكن ان تقابل ذلك ايضا بصدر
مفتوح يعني هذه الرسائل المتبادله تعكس
فهما سياسيا مختلفا ال- ال- الاعلانات
الصينيه همم في سياقه الدبلوماسيه تميل
الى التاكيد على التعايش وعلى التعاون
اليه ايجابيه في السياق
في الواقع على الارض هي تذهب باتجاه مختلف
الصينيون عبر هذا ارسلوا رساله بارعه
بخصوص التنوع والتكيف مع وجود الاخر
والامريكيون ايضا بعثته بالرسالته من
تقليديه لهذا الخصوص لا نريد صراعا مع
الصين نحن في اطار تنافس معكم لكن ينبغي
ان يكون هذا التنافس السلميا لا يتحول
الانتهاء من بعض الاولويات الامريكيه في
العالم حاليا شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور عقيل
عباس الخبير في شؤون السياسيه من واشنطن
تحياتي اليك شكرا
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا رئيس اندونيسيا يؤكد
ان الثبات فن وان ثمنها غالي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
النصفيه
وهم يحاولون معرفه من يستطيع ان يعبر
بالحزب الى بر الامان الصحيفه اشارت الى
ان المحادثات الخاصه بين المانحين للحزب
تركز على ما يعتقدون انها قد تكون افضل
فرصه لهم لتهميش
زعامه مجلس الشيوخ وتحقيق مكاسب اقل من
المتوقع في مجلس النواب والسبب هم
المرشحون ذو الاراء المتطرفه من الذين
حققوا نتائج سيئه من جانبه كسر ترامب بشان
اخفاقات الانتخابات النصفيه ليلق باللومه
على زعيم الاقليه في مجلس الشيوخ متش
مكانل اعتبر ترامب ان مكان الانفق الاموال
بشكل خاطئ ما ادى لهزيمه المرشحين كما انه
لم يقدم الدعم لعدد من المرشحين الذين
دعمهم ترامب اكثر من مره دعت رامبل لاقاله
من منصبه وجدد دعوته هذا الاسبوع عندما
اعتبر ان السيناتور ريكست سيكون افضل شخص
حاليا لقياده الجمهوريين بمجلس الشيوخ رغم
خساره مرشحين الاسبوع الماضي ما زال ترامب
صاحب شعبيه في حزبه نقلت واشنطن بوست عن
مخططين جمهورينا قولهم ان نسبه تاييد
الجمهوريين لترامب تصل الى 40%
[موسيقى]
لكن اذا قرر الجمهوريون تغيير ترامب فمن
ابرز المرشحين لخلافته واشنطن بوست حاولت
الاستقرار وزير الخارج
الخميس الماضي
وقال ان المرشحين الجمهوريين يتم انتخابهم
عندما يقدمون برامج
في الانتخابات التمهيديه عام 2016 اضافه
اليه في المركز الثالث
ان النائب الرئيس السابق
على حبل رفيع بين البقاء على المنهج
تجنب اغضاب ترامب خلال كتاب سيصدره غدا
لكنه قال في لقاء تلفزيوني ان خطوات ترامب
عرضت الكثيرين للخطر الى المركز الثاني
نجد هنا دونالد ترامب الذي يسعى للوصول
لولايه الثانيه له غير متتابعه او متواليه
للبيت الابيض اما المركز الاول فيحل في
حاكم ولايه فلوريدا وهو ران ديسانتس خاصه
بعد ان اتسح منافسه الديمقراطي بفارق 20
نقطه واظهر استطلاع اجرته يوجا الشهر
الماضي ان ديسانتس يبتعد ب 90 نقاط فقط عن
ترامب في حال ما اذا تواجهات في
الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوري لكن
ما راي المواطنين الامريكيين هذه شريحه
منهم
ساوند
ستاندر
فيديو اليوم
واخيرا جاءت من تساعد السيده الاولى على
النهوض ثم استمرت المراسم وما زال الرئيس
يتحرك بثبات ليحيي مستقبليه
عليها بالتاكيد هنا يذهب الزوجان الى مقر
اقامته ما سيكون على الرئيس ان يحفظه هناك
على ثباته وان يشرح للسيده الاولى سببا
هذا التبات
الله يساعدك على كل الاحوال
في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 لم نتمكن
من جمع اموال من المستثمرين ولا من الحصول
على قرض محلي قصير الامد التصريح
جولد البريطانيه للملابس التي تستعد
لتقديم طلب افلاس بعد نفاد السيوله
الماليه لديها
معها الف و600 موظف مع 132 متجر ستغلق
ابوابها
الصوره اليوم
طاهر في مدينته التي يحب على ارضها وتحت
اشجارها اختار هذا الرجل ان تكون نوماته
الاخيره نومه طويله
بالاشكركم يد العون لان الكل كانوا
مشغولين اما بقوه تنسحب او باخرى تهاجم في
الحرب من يموتون ليس بسبب رصاصه بل بسبب
النسيان بسبب حبه دواء لم تاتي في الموت
الممثل الامريكي الخاص الايراني يقول ناس
في عدم تنسيق دول الغرب بشان تحريرها في
ايران و نحن نحكم اخبار العربيه 360